il se passait des choses extraordinaires
parce que les ukrainiens ont repris la
main sur la guerre donc en fait vous ont
fait une offensive tous ceux qui sont
partis en été pendant les vacances là
depuis le mois d'août les ukrainiens ont
attaqué les russes ils sont mêmes
maintenant ils ont appris à se servir
des armes occidentales qui sont très
précise très très puissante très très
bonne donc ils ont été aidés par
l'occident c'est ça donc c'est ce que
dit vladimir poutine c'est ce que
malheureusement vous dit vladimir
poutine et malheureusement il n'a pas
forcément tort là c'est ça quand ils
pensent d'abord à la grande bretagne à
la france il repense non d'abord aux
états unis d'abord états unis aux états
unis angleterre allemagne et la france
arrive en 7e position on n'est jamais
premier nulle part si c'est si c'est fou
dans la gastronomie dans l'est dans le
luxe la france il ya un première série à
part dans le pôle dans les sacs à main
et l'état on est on est on est premiers
nuls pas alors il a souhaité faire
passer un message
qu'est ce qu'il a voulu dire de la
divers poutine aujourd'hui il fait là il
lit là c'est la première fois au mois
j'ai peur a vraiment pas parce que vous
n'aviez jamais eu peur ouais
disons que vous mentionnez la première
fois content et quand je suis arrivé le
24 quand elle a lancé la grande guerre
bah je vous ai parlé tout de suite du
nucléaire ouais et tout le monde m'a
traitée de mythos d'ailleurs raconte
n'importe quoi elle connaît rien en
russie que ces trois jours après poutine
qu on voit que son ministre de la
défense je bous son chef d'état-major
gasimov et il dit quoi mettez les forces
nucléaires en alerte
donc tout le monde a rassemblé tout de
suite la vie finalement ne raconte pas
que des conneries c'est que vous avez
été invité par tous derrière chaque fois
qu'on a vite quelque 400 et après il y
avait évidemment ils achètent un blouson
en cuir à pondre depuis seulement on
s'en fout du nucléaire actuellement
parce que là on parti sérieux a bien sûr
parce que depuis sept mois chaque
semaine il nous remet une couche si
c'est pas lui c'est lavrov demi des
affaires étrangères si c'est pas lavrov
c'est medvedev l'ancien président qui
lui a tenu en fait et jusqu'à maintenant
on se disait ça va il nous fait il nous
fait le poker menteur est donc surtout
jusqu'à la dernière semaine la dernière
semaine il était à onze mais qui ce
temps pour assommer avec notamment 6 in
ping le dire le dirigeant chinois et on
a commencé à se calmer parce que poutine
était humiliée la semaine dernière à
mort il y avait quatre personnes qui
l'ont fait attendant d'abord c'est lui
qui fait attendre vous savez il a fait
attendre le pape deux heures avec la
reine d'angleterre cac 40 minutes la
reine d'angleterre il l'a fait attendre
quarante minutes elle était là en train
de la pauvre
là on l'a fait attendre et là on a fait
attendre en plus il ya il ya le premier
ministre chinois qui lui a dit vous
savez vladimir la guerre c'est pas bon
il faut il faudra avoir la paix et
qu'est-ce que poutine lui répond il dit
je vais finir je vais essayer je
comprends votre inquiétude et je vais
rapidement finir cette guerre et quatre
jours après il nous sort ce truc ça veut
dire quoi va finir rapidement c'est le
gars ou alors dites-nous bah justement
c'est ça le problème c'est ça le
problème parce que on a compris que au
niveau d'armes conventionnelles il peut
pas gagner cette guerre ça je vous ai
dit le premier jour où je venais m'avait
dit de toute façon avec un pays comme
l'ukraine en face même s'ils n'ont pas
assez d'armes il ne pourra jamais gagner
cette guerre parce que les ukrainiens
vont défendre leur terre leur mère leur
eau leur frère leur soeur norsys leur
territoire leur nation et la poutine l'a
compris parce que il a perdu 50 mille
hommes quand même rien que en ces
énormes afghanistan dix en union
soviétique ses 15000 hommes là on sept
mois 50 et dissémine l'une en lui
dissimule
deux côtés mais il a perdu quand même 50
milles plus les blessés ça veut dire et
il avait perdu quasiment tout tout tout
l'armé qu'il avait au début de la guerre
est ce qu il en train de perdre la
guerre contre l'ukraine ou
il est en train de perdre la guerre
conventionnelle c'est ça donc là il va
dire conventionnelles pour ceux qui ne
comprennent pas c lagarde classique et
servir comme pendant la deuxième guerre
la première guerre avec les charmes et
les canons que c est
et c'est ça ce que je vous disais aussi
à plusieurs reprises quand il sentira
qu'il ne peut pas gagner cette guerre
d'une manière classique au conventionnel
qu'est ce qu'il lui reste
bah voilà nucléaire c'est lui qui a dit
il c'est pas moi c'est lui qui a dit non
mais c'est vrai là et donc et 2 et le
nucléaire il a parlé au jeudi mais vous
avez vu le culot alors le nucléaire pour
les téléspectateurs ça serait quoi voilà
pourquoi le nucléaire si l arme de
destruction massive sellam larmes qui
fait peur c'est larmes qui n'a jamais
utilisé était utilisé sauf qu'une seule
fois par les américains en 1945 contre
les japonais adieu reprise donc
hiroshima et nagasaki
et pour utiliser sa contre l'ukraine et
il pourrait utiliser ça au début quand
on crève mais ce qui est inquiétant
c'est ce même pas ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il a dit je mène pas la
guerre contre le cren je mène la guerre
contre vous à l'occident temps
l'occident c'est ça c'est tout
l'occident qui est derrière et je
considère lui enfin lui il considère que
c'est tout l'occident qui lui fait
l'alsace donc comme vous avez dit les
états unis en premier lieu les états
membres et la grande bretagne
l'allemagne la france etc et est donc ça
c'est la première chose inquiétante et
de toute façon donc les armes nucléaires
si jamais les emplois c'est ce sera la
première fois en 60 ans et c'est une
arme dans lesquels on sait comment on
part on sait plus comment on s'arrête
et moi j'avais j'avais un tout petit peu
d'espoir hier hier la dent dans la
soirée lorsqu'il devait se prononcer
prononcer ce discours hier à 20h heure
de moscou et puis ils annulent et puis
tout personne ne comprend pourquoi ils
annulent peut-être qu'il a changé d'avis
peut-être il est tué peut-être qu'il ya
quelque chose peut-être il est
emprisonné peut être il ya les généraux
qui ont compris qu'ils ont faire un coup
d'état donc il y avait des spéculations
hier toute la soirée et toute la nuit
j'ai quasiment pas dormi cette nuit
j'attendais qu'est ce qu'il disait est
ce qu'il ya une fuite qui va sortir en
disant que finalement une en prison ça y
est c'est terminé la guerre est terminée
et ce matin il prononce son discours est
donc dur très dur très dur donc en plus
au nucléaire ou ça vous
vous avez que le culot avec lequel il
raconte ça il dit l'ukraine a fait la
tentative d'acquérir l'armé nucléaire
attendez l'ukraine n'a pas d'armes
nucléaires l'ukraine à la sortie du res
avec les armes nucléaires elle a préféré
mais donner à la russie
donc elle a signé un accord qui
s'appelle l'accord de budapest en
1994 et la russie lui garantissait sa
sécurité et ce mec là il a le culot de
dire les ukrainiens me menace de nuit
parce que vous êtes en train de nous
dire aussi c'est que une guerre pourrait
éclater entre la russie et notamment la
france
le tout c'est que s'il passe ce qui
pourrait se passer là c'est à dire tu
ferais quoi ils enverraient ça c'est
quoi ça va jouer dans l'exotique dans
les prochains jours ça peut jouer
n'importe quand là on est en goudron nez
on est vraiment dans je ne voudrais pas
faire peur mais la situation est
vraiment vraiment difficile bien sûr ça
veut dire que en fait lui il est acculé
acculé il a compris et les généraux ont
compris un russe qu'il ne perd pas
qu'ils ne peuvent pas vacances et l
ukraine est donc à on espérait qu'ils le
comprennent et qu'ils disent la guerre
est finie on signe la paix avec les
ukrainiens l'accord les sanctions
tombent et c est lui à la place de ça
mais il ne sort ça se sent pas ça il va
vouloir gagner la guerre coûte 20 voilà
donc la caisse qui feraient ils
enverraient d'abord ils attaqueront avec
le nucléaire l'ukraine d'abord en
principe il peut employer ce qu'on
appelle le nucléaire tactique
d'accord c'est à dire contre le crime
une tactique ça venir c'est une petite
bombe nucléaire celle qui qui était qui
était employé à hiroshima et nagasaki
ces 15 kilotonnes 15 20 kilotonnes la
science grecque et le tone ça détruit
une ville de 50 mille habitants ce qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé pour eux
donc on fait ça détruit disons un
territoire de 5 km totalement et puis ça
fait les dégâts avec 10 km 15 km auto et
ça pour vous c'est une petite ça c'est
hiroshima mais
bombes nucléaires tactiques c'est plus
petit que ça oui c'est pour ça que ça ça
peut détruire un kilomètre avec les
dégâts 5 km autour et puis radiations
qui va rester quelques semaines deux
trois quatre semaines sur place et donc
continuer à tuer les gens avec la
radiation ça c'est la même tactique et
donc par exemple et peut me faire sur la
capitale de l'ukraine kiev lancé sur le
palais présidentiel là où il ya zelensky
mai et donc ça détruira le quartier dans
lequel se trouve ce palais et
quelle serait la réaction internationale
je crois que la poutine ne se rend pas
compte en fait il est il est devenu fou
en fait si c'est quelqu'un qui s'est
enfermé complètement dans sa bulle il ne
comprend plus rien qu'est ce qui se
passe et commence à croire dans les
mensonges qu'il raconte et donc il est
persuadé que ce que que ce qu'il raconte
est vrai et donc il ne peut pas y laisse
imaginer que si jamais ils emploient ça
c'est la ligne rouge de toutes les
lignes rouges
ça veut dire il deviendra par ya déjà la
russie subit les sanctions la ruse
l'économie russe ne marche pas
contrairement à certains qui disent non
les échos les sanctions marchent plutôt
fort mal chez nous ici plutôt qu'en
russie c'est faux la russie a déjà perdu
des capitaux et l'a perdu déjà la
production le gasprom le fleuron gaga
les gaziers et la production de pétrole
chute donc la russie souffre déjà mais
s'il s'il franchit cette ligne là
d'abord il va devenir parias de chez
paria s'il est d'accord la cour il s'en
fiche info je ne crois pas enfin lui
peut-être les peut-être il sent qu'ils
ont tort de lui même à la fin c'est ça
mais on est mélangé j'ai l'espoir de
passer ce que tu disais vu de
l'intérieur enfin on fait les l'espoir
que je vous disais j'ai l'espoir dans
les gens surtout dans les voleurs qui
ont volé pendant 20 ans du fric et qui
ont ramassé des milliards et maintenant
ils vont tous se tout perdre 5 milliards
jean-michel jouer pour répondre à la
question faut-il s'attendre au pire ça
me rappelle que dans tous les derniers
conflits mondiaux les gens n'y croyaient
pas jusqu'à quelques jours avant le
déclenchement donc vous moi je suis
quand même inquiet parce que les champs
quelques jours avant la première guerre
mondiale aux deuxième guerre mondiale
tout le monde pensait qu'il aurait pas
de guerre est bonne ça nous est tombé
dessus comme ça ne faut pas prendre les
déclarations des relations anales gère
l'engrenage va très vite il suffit d'une
attaque dispo personnes que les autres
ou disproportionnée pour
qu'immédiatement on peut décider de
riposter et que du coup ça fascine
déclare une une catastrophe en chaîne et
qu'il ya une surenchère chaque fois des
arbres c'est vrai qu'ils une tactique on
peut les mettre dans une endroit peu
habité uniquement pour à effet de
dissuasion vous dire arrêtez maintenant
autrement je les utilisais dame plus
forte et du coup là ça m'a vraiment
faire mal mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
croiser ce bon quelques quartiers où il
ya du scion tout matériel mais c'est un
engrenage qui peut aller très très vite
exactement deux mots engrenages et
réactions en chaîne sa super c'est
justement ça ça veut dire que en fait
bien évidemment l'ukraine ne peux pas
répondre à cette nature mais il ya déjà
le premier ministre britannique boris
johnson qui a dit que si jamais poutine
frappé la grande bretagne répondra avec
une arme unitaire à la place parce que
ce mémorandum de budapest de 1994 il ya
les états unis et l'angleterre qui sont
aussi nous garant de sécurité de
l'ukraine est donc pour lui faire peur
et pour lui faire comprendre qu'elle
doit s'arrêter ils peuvent répondre le
problème c'est que s ils n'auraient pas
et s'ils ne s'arrête pas et alors c'est
la réaction en chaîne juin c'est alors
c'est lui encore nous encore lui encore
non encore et là c'est la troisième
guerre mondiale
et si c'est parti comme ça alors là
c'est foutu pour tout le monde et on
voit de vous montrer ses propos avaient
tous ept propagandistes russe olga sa
kabaeva connaissez vous connaissez à
l'expliquer que la russie aurait dû
bombardé la grande-bretagne pendant les
funérailles de la guerre delà de la
reine elizabeth ii à lons je peux vous
dire que si bertrand decker s'arrêter là
elle y va et on rigole on rigole par un
touareg l'avancé coupez cote mes moyens
des manifestations très forte à moscou
qui sont réprimées bien sûr des jeunes
et des femmes mais c'est quand même un
signal il paraît que tous les avions
sont pris d'assaut si oui
alors justement sergei quelles seraient
les conséquences et pour tous les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
quelles seraient les conséquences pour
la france est ce que la france serait
basso sera en guerre pour être en guerre
dans l'est dans les prochains jours non
je ne crois j'espère que non j'espère
que non mais c'est pas parce que
j'espère que la france ne sera pas ne
parle pas de guerre et ne sera pas
impliqué de ce guerre
qu'on peut pas dire que poutine lui il
s'en fout de la situation en fait en
fait vous avez compris il ya des gens
qui disent pourquoi on ne fait pas la
paix avec lui pourquoi on ne propose pas
les pourparlers pour qu'on ne fasse pas
de la désescalade parce que il veut pas
de l'escalette il ne comprend rien le
medvedev son ancien premier président il
veut pas la désescalade et ils font tous
me la montée la montée la montée est
donc président macron la con
nations-unies avant-hier il a prononcé
un discours très ferme il a expliqué
aussi aux nations-unies au pays qui
soutiennent toutim qu'il faut pas le
soutenir il faut au moins lui montrer
qu'on est con et or qu'on n'est pas
derrière lui et y compris en ne faisant
rien parce qu'il ya plein de pays par
exemple les pays africains où les pays
des herbiers asiatiques qui ne sont pas
avec lui mais qui vote m notre la chine
la chine le soutien voilà lâché je
passerai en k2 en cas d'attaqué des
russes justement si la grande bretagne
que vous l'avez dit derrière riposte
qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer parce
que c'est vrai que la chine est quand
même un maillon important ils feraient
quoi la chine ferait quoi en principe de
la chine dit je suis très loin les etats
unis disent la même chose nous on est
dans le côté de la planète etats unis
bien sûr bien sûr que si bien sûr que si
donc en fait ses armes nucléaires on a
parlé d' armes tactiques après vous avez
les armes qui on allait porter
différentes vous avez les armes de
petite portée même pour des canaux - qui
ont déporté à 20 30 40 50 95 nommé au
même en nucléaire après vous avez le
nucléaire opérationnel c'est jusqu'à 200
km 300 km avez vous avez le nucléaire
moyens porter ces jusqu'à 5000 km et
après vous avez le nucléaire
stratégiques intercontinentaux et là ça
peut aller n'importe où sur la terre est
ce que joe biden et vladimir poutine se
parlent n'ont malheureusement pas du
tout donc c'est ça aussi le nom parce
que joe biden en fait là choisi la
fermeté de langage pas à poutine il a
dit face à ce que poutine a fait aboutir
à herpen ce sont les villes selon les
banlieues dans le or de kiev où ils ont
massacré des gens massacrer des civils
en fait on a découvert ça lorsque les
russes se sont retirés le 31 mars ils
ont laissé ces villes est donc là c'est
les ukrainiens mais a aussi la
communauté internationale qui est venu
et là c'est c'est l'horreur c'est
l'horreur est en fait président macron
par exemple ils avaient ils disaient oui
il faut pousser les ukrainiens vert vers
la paix pour conclure les
pod la paix avec les russes y est allé
mois de juin abuja il a changé de
discours il a changé de discours depuis
fin juin président macron a complètement
changé de discours et dit poutine mène
une guerre impérialiste il s'en fout de
tout le monde et donc il n'y a que avec
une réponse ferme il dit il dit que
l'occident veut détruire la russie c'est
faux et est ce que est ce que la france
c'est fois c'est la question que tout le
monde se pose aussi ce soir là on pense
bien sûr tout le monde est ce que la
france pourrait
être subir une attaque nucléaire la
france pourrait subir une attaque
nucléaire contre n'importe quel autre
pays qui représente l'occident donc
l'allemagne la grande bretagne les états
unis mais la france peut répondre que la
france est une puissance nucléaire ah
ouais et le problème il est là aussi
parce que si la russie attaque la france
nucléaire la france peut et peut-être
répondra du point de vue ni clair est-ce
qu'il ya des moyens de se défendre oui
la france a des moyens de se défendre il
se défendre en attaquant ou se défendre
dans ceux dépendant des halles se
défendant parce que vous savez d'abord
on espère avec poutine on espère que la
moitié de ces missiles sont des missiles
soviétiques et donc ils vont peut-être
même pas partir parce qu'ils sont là
depuis 40 ans ils sont là depuis
longtemps et donc ça se trouve que c'est
comme avec les chars vous savez il ya
plein de chars soviétiques qui sont
arrivés en ukraine qui sont tombés en
panne et sa voix là et donc on espère
qu'il ya peut-être la moitié des
missiles qui vont pas partir enfin comme
les autres
puis s'est allongé mais la sécu il ya
l'autre il ya l'autre moitié qui qui va
quand même partir après les pays
occidentaux dont la france ont la
possibilité de se défendre avec les
antimissiles donc en france vous avez
les antilles missive de confort à battre
assez loin du territoire français les
missiles convoi parce que dès que les
missiles parts de russie on les voit
tout le monde les voit tout le monde a
des radars un missile qui part de russie
la rive combien de temps après on va
c'est ça le problème c'est ça le
problème parce qu'en fait les anciens
modèles de domicile et mettront
peut-être une demi heure 20 minutes mais
ils ont actuellement les missiles qui
sont très rapides et donc est d'ailleurs
la même la même personne la même femme
là de la chaîne de la première chaîne
télévisuelle ils ont montré aussi ce
missile qui s'appelle sarmates qui
mettra cinq minutes entre quatre et cinq
minutes pour arriver en faire l'amère
manifestation s'est attaquée par la mer
c'est plus rapide c'est ça lorsque les
bars on peut se faire attaquer aussi par
la mer parce qu'il ya les sous-marins ca
les sous marins stratégiques russes qui
peuvent être dans l'océan atlantique et
à ce moment là c'est juste
dans quelques minutes justement jean
michel gaieté reporter de guerre impôts
voilà l'histoire donc c'est vrai qu'il
est très impliqué il connaît bien le
dossier vous vouliez dire quelque chose
et non parce que c'est vrai qu'on
parlait de distillation c'est vraiment
les silos nucléaire qu'on connaît que
les américains connaissent whisky sont
placés que ça c'est plus pour montrer
c'est sa force se montrer les bras mais
là la plage sera la véritable menace
c'est les sous marins nucléaires
lanceurs d'engins qui ne peuvent se
déplacer n'importe où dans le monde sait
à peu près des côtes américaines même
sauf si vraiment il ya une attaque de ce
mois et du coup lancé la porte et n'est
pas importante ils peuvent se mettre au
large de new york et va lancer un
missile iskander à n'importe quel moment
ils sont très difficiles à détecter et
les gardes les guerres entre sous marins
sap et beaucoup de dégâts avant qu'on
arrive à l'arrêter surtout qu'une fois
qu'ils commencent à rentrer en guerre
ils se mettent complètement en autonomie
ils écoutent plus tous on leur dit même
si ça bien de leur propre camp ce qu'ils
peuvent dire que nous ils ont été
attaqués du coup c'est des fausses
informations du coup une fac à sous
marins nucléaires lanceurs d'engins il
part dans une mission plus rien ne peut
l'arrêter à partie quand il a reçu
l'ordre de tirer il va lancer leurs
coutumes annoncé la miss il coûte que
coûte même si on line ou non d'arrêter
une oreille quand même
aujourd'hui la france a une position
très ferme
vous nous dites qu'on arrive dans les
voilà aujourd'hui les animaux poutine
mais on veut surtout aux états-unis la
grande-bretagne à l'allemagne à la
france est ce qui pourrait aller en
guerre contre tous ces pays parce qu'il
serait ce qu'un petit peu isolé aussi
puisque vous nous dites même la chine je
pense que la chine rentrera pas en
guerre avec lui la laissera elle
regardera ça de loin mais elle prendra
pas part au conflit je dirais que si
poutine est une personne raisonnable il
peut pas le faire parce qu'il sait de
toute façon que dans la guerre nucléaire
et peut pas y avoir de vainqueur mais
tout le monde perdra y compris cc c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs et hier quand un
chantier une annonce comme quoi il était
son discours était retardé je me disais
c'est peut-être les chinois qui ont
téléphoné en disant
voir et tout le monde comme on dit et on
le hait ce que dix ans tu nous laisses
et spécialiste de géopolitique que la
chine là est
le seul pays à pouvoir peut-être le
réseau n'a arrêté et se confie et le
raisonner josy mais aujourd'hui le
président chinois il est dans un voilà
on laisse son le on laisse faire on
réagit pas on y va on y va doucement
c'est à dire qu'il est pas il exprime
pas une énorme fermeté envers vladimir
poutine a disons que les chinois n'ont
pas de fermeté par rapport à la russie
parce que ils vont et ils ont tout à
gagner c'est ça c'est que si jamais la
russie s'enfonce encore plus dans la
guerre c'est ce que en gros en fait la
chine c'est le voisin à côté de la
russie sauf que ce voisin a énormément
de population est très fort
économiquement il manque de ressources
et de l'autre côté vous avez la russie
où il ya plein de ressources et
quasiment pas d'homme et donc les
chinois se disent si la russie
s'affaiblit c'est la russie devient
sanctionnés nous on va récupérer tous
les toutes les matières premières qui
sont de l'autre côté et donc en fait
c'est pour le sucre rhum les etats unis
aussi ah si c'est intéressant pour les
chimie sur la chine mais non puisque ils
vont dire que les états unis vont
s'affaiblir forcément s'ils rentrent en
dix ans face à la russie là l'europe va
s'affaiblir également et c'est vrai que
bénéfice pour les états unis ça
intéresse doublement mais les chinois
parce qu'ils ont les visées sur taïwan
c'est ça et taiwan est défendu par en
principe pour être défendue par les
états unis dont ils se disent la cible
les états unis s'affaiblissent aussi de
leur côté à ce moment là ils pourront
plus réagir par rapport à taïwan si
jamais la chinoise est pour ça que la
chine qui est un petit peu vraiment la
pierre angulaire en vrai un même si on
livre on les voit pas beaucoup dans ce
conflit c'est vraiment la pierre
angulaire du conflit en vrai on s'est eu
il serait plus favorable à un conflit
mondial non je ne crois pas que ils
seront favoris à part au contre et au
mondial il et pousseront la russie a mon
avis tu penses qu'on la russie peut-être
même jusqu'à nucléaire sur l'ukraine
d'accord mais continue au conflit
mondial finalement la chine n'a pas
tellement envie de le faire parce que la
chine c'est une puissance économique et
la puissance économique la moitié des
lits rap à la chine elle a le fera pas
ce que je vous dis merci si jamais il ya
la guerre nucléaire ça va ça va arriver
partout c'est pas moi j'étais loin corée
du nord peut s'exciter aussi tout oui
bien sûr la corée du nord peu oui mais
voilà après c'est vrai que c'est et on
voit on va vous poser la plaine des
questions encore un sérieux et je sais
que vous êtes très nombreux à vouloir
réagir là-dessus parce que voilà on vous
explique très très didactique mans ce
qui peut se passer oui aussi qu'ils sont
vraiment deux débutants mais mais il
n'est pas fou rire c'est que si par
hasard il déclencher la guerre avec en
face tous les pays d'europe plus des
états unis plus l'angleterre qui europe
maintenant si tous ces pays se mettre
contre lui il aura perdu bien avant il
sens d'avoir tué deux saisines qui sait
que si déclenché la guerre qui tue son
pays oui mais il y aura deux y aura une
guerre finie une guerre nucléaire tout
le monde perd j'ai la réponse à ça on
aura touché son pays bien avant le bien
avant bien avant qu'ils aient mis dans
ses autres parce que le cinéma au
service il a répondu à ça alors
figurez-vous il a répondu à ça on lui a
posé cette question en 2018 je les ai
mis dans le livre dans mon livre
l'engrenage qui que j'ai consacré à
cette analyse de ces de cette guerre est
donc je cite poutine on lui a posé la
question mais vous savez si jamais la
guerre nucléaire arrive c c'est tout le
monde est perdant il a dit oui ce sera
la catastrophe pour l'humanité mais est
ce que cette humanité a le droit
d'exister c'est la russie c'est ma
routine n'existe pas c'est ça oui les
finances
a répondu a déclaré avec cette personne
voulait avoir des pourparlers de paix ça
résume tout c'est à dire lg voient non
parce qu'on parlait pendant la publicité
je suis demandée pour pour qui
travaillaient et quel était son parcours
à qu'il avait répondu les deux et quel
était l'intérêt de voilà pour au vu de
la catastrophe qui s'annonce planétaire
est-ce que la responsabilité de l'europe
n'est pas vraiment de pousser à une
désescalade urgemment parce que personne
va gagner peut-être que lui il est fou
et je ne soutiens absolument pas ce
qu'il a fait et c'est maintenant je vois
simplement que selon les pays l'arménie
par exemple été attaqué par
l'azerbaïdjan n'a pas du tout les mêmes
réponses on fait même des deals pour le
gaz et c'est donc le point de vue moral
c'est une chose mais il ya aussi des
choses concrètes on sent beaucoup mieux
et influencé beaucoup de conflits en
afrique où la france
voilà parfait mais
c'est quand même pas réellement etc oui
d'accord mais vous parlez toujours du
côté de poutine est ce que notre
responsabilité en tant qu occident en
tant que europe n'est pas de pousser
urgemment a des propositions à faire
tout parce qu'en fait le dernier
discours de d'ursula von der leyen qui
est quant à elle été en bleu et jaune
elle annoncé que la guerre allait durer
des années et c'est en fait on sent pas
je ne vois pas et peut-être que je ne
les ai pas vus et je ne suis pas du tout
experte donc peut-être vous allez me
répondre est ce qu'il ya des gens qui
activent m'en propose des solutions de
négociation au lieu de deux parce que
lui nous considère comme des colos
belligérants puisque on envoie des armes
etc et donc à un moment donné
qu'elle est en train de dire dégueulasse
que la politique européenne dont la
politique d' emmanuel macron c'est ce
qu'elle pointe n'est pas trop dur par
rapport à ce conflit et il ya beaucoup
de jours jolanne il ya beaucoup de gens
sur les réseaux aussi voilà qu'ils
disent est ce que la france ne fait pas
un petit peu trop et c'est vrai que
c'est ce qu'on entend de plus en plus on
a vu ségolène royal aussi s'exprimer il
ya quelques semaines il ya de plus en
plus dorée civile et nous régale c'est
la mère ce qu'elle a à dire ces besoins
a annoncé que ségolène royal était pour
poutine
on a mal interprété ce qu'elle a dit ces
gars-là dit ce qu'elle a dit à peu près
tout est là des voix l'a dit est ce que
on n'a pas une politique un peu trop du
et on y est ce que voilà est-ce qu'on
s'y prend bien c'est ce cas là la
réponse est très claire emmanuel macron
à passer au téléphone senteurs avec
poutine depuis le début de la guerre
senteurs d'un gros forcé
et et finalement pour comprendre quoi
que poutine s'en foutent et de lui ouais
pendant ces senteurs poutine s'en
foutent et emmanuel macron 2010 et il
faut trouver la voie il faut trouver un
moyen de négocier il faut trouver un
moyen de de faire la paix sans heurts au
téléphone mais quand est ce que est ce
que alors la réponse est non mais si
sebastian en récit à l'arrêt la réponse
la réponse est ce que le président
français s'est entretenu avec le
président chinois
ça c'est une bonne question parce que
c'est la clé on le sait il faut vraiment
ça c'est parce que tu vois là je vous le
dis c'est une bonne que ça sert à rien
d'appeler poutine pour moi il faut
appeler le président chinois hu shuli
c'est la seule chose qui pouvait il faut
que tous les présidents fasse pression
sur le président chinois c'est le seul
qui peut désamorcer poutine il
n'écoutera personne d'autre il est
actuellement que la chaîne joue le
docteur n'y a personne est actuellement
beaucoup de chefs d'état et de deux
chefs de gouvernement qui sont aux
nations unies parce qu'il ya l'assemblée
générale des nations unies d'habitude il
ya le discours bien évidemment à tout le
monde sans faim ce qyi qui peuvent
prononcer le discours et pendant ce
discours mais il ya énormément de
travail diplomatique dans les couloirs
et là il ya tout le monde qui cherchent
les métaux que ça veut dire que faut pas
faut pas croire que on est on est là on
va t'en guerre tout le monde veut ça
veut dire bien son va-t-en-guerre sur
les plateaux télé il ya beaucoup de gens
qui est de l'attention la population à
adopter une opinion favorable de lui
c'est le cas de beaucoup de gens non je
veux dire il ya beaucoup qui les
connaissent bien sûr ils connaissent
rien elle a raison qui n'y connaissent
rien en conflit et qui font des appels à
aller voilà
battre en ukraine ex tard il faut déjà
vraiment savoir ce qui se passe dans le
monde lui aujourd'hui on est face à
quelqu'un avec qui vous l'avez dit on ne
peut qu elle qu on ne peut pas raisonner
donc il faut essayer de voir quels
seraient les stratégies les moyens de
pression les lélés qui pourrait le faire
payer parce que il ya il ya quand même
quelques moyens de pression quand même
oui on a vu qu'on a vu que le
durcissement voilà
l'ailé les différentes sanctions qui ont
été prises contre la russie n'ont pas du
tout marché à marcher que la wii ça
marche
ça n'a pas du tout marché sur georges
dimur poutine
ça marche chez nous mais ça marche ça
marche sur la russie aussi mais ça
marche aussi non pas sur lui mais en
france on voit que là on va on va au
devant de gros problèmes il ya beaucoup
de français moi moi je vous dire et ont
cessé ses jeux secs raymond il sait ce
que je veux dire il ya beaucoup de
français qui disent c'est pas nous et
qu'est ce qu'elle vient de dire que
vient de dire quoi de dire dans ces cas
là notre guerre et on va se cet hiver on
va payer des sommes folles je dis pas
que c'est moi qui pense à meilhan mais
c'est beaucoup de lait a beaucoup de
réactions comme ça sur les réseaux
sociaux on va pas se mentir et daniel ce
que tu as dit arriver raymond saissac
tous les liens on doit on doit être
solidaire bien sûr on a envie d'être
solidaire des ukrainiens on a envie de
les aider contre contre le méchant
poutine mais nous des fois on se dit
c'est on n'a pas à payer deux euros
l'essence n'a pas payé l'électricité des
augmentations qui nous promet ce qui
nous promettent baisser la baisser le
chauffage chez vous il ya des gens déjà
il n'arrive même pas à chauffer à 19 ne
me dise faut qu'on soit 19 presse avec
18 là il parle de taxer ce qui ne plaît
plus hauts revenus ils vont payer
l'électricité plus cher que les autres
il ya des gens qui arrivent même pas
chauffé vraiment là on a tout eu alors
on y va franchement franchement où on
n'a pas refait cette guerre
va payer pendant dix ans ouais
d'arméniens il ya beaucoup
pourquoi on a laissé faire énormément de
guerre et égard je suis je suis désolé
on s'en remet en afrique on a on a john
elway
on a laissé faire des choses voilà
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que l'ukraine
mine de rien la mer quand même il ya
quand même y'a quand même des noms qu'on
ya des enjeux économiques
oui voilà et encore une fois on voit
passer les enjeux économiques qui prime
aujourd'hui voilà une crème à faire
partie de l'europe c'est pour ça oui
mais je n ignore les raisons de ces
questions très honnête il ya quinze
jours personne ne savait où c'était sur
une cane s'adresser même pas qu'il
existait
connaissez le nom mais savait pas que
les pare brise des voitures c'était bien
elle va cette fois qu'une portière
c'était lui que maintenant nous avons la
résine végétale j'avais pas demande une
plaquette de frein j'ai pas les miettes
de france à cause de l'ukraine et les
mecs si cela met notre vie matière
économique du monde un pays on savait
même pas qu'il existait ya un mois sur
un petit tube run est
non mais mathieu mathieu alors ou ne dit
pas mathieu mille pattes à son sarouel
dit je vous dire géraldine maillet je
vous adore je vous êtes un petit peu
hors sol vous êtes à saint germain des
prés les gens qui nous regardent non
mais je ne sais pas où mais vous aussi
pour passer devant
les gens qui nous regardent et les gens
comme moi comme mathieu comme raymond je
suis désolé on se pose la question
mafieuses qui dit ça résume beaucoup de
ce que lisent les gens sur les réseaux
sociaux je suis désolé mathieu tu es
allé jusqu'à envoyer des soldats de
france est de 20 euros sans se faire
tuer pour une guerre qui est en
guerre mondiale la fin
vite non je ne crois pas parce que les
pays occidentaux ont d'autres moyens
pour se défendre donc les missiles on
n'a pas besoin d'envoyer des soldats
d'ailleurs les nouvelles guerres les
guerres nouvelle c'est ce que les
ukrainiens ont prouvé ça joue sajou
jours avec les missiles alors rapport à
la situation économique c'est légitime
de poser les questions bein sauf que il
ya beaucoup de mythes par exemple
j'aurais passé on a parlé de gaz on a
dit au foot ils ferment le robinet la
france bat ce cahier pendant tout
l'hiver vous savez combien ça pèse le
gaz russe dans la balance et l'énergie
qui s'en servaient pour cent non le gaz
pèse 15 % dans la balance érigé
énergétique dans ses cales world 117%
c'est le gaz russe la règle de trois
cases par 17000 / son c'est
2,72 % poutine faire de leurs journées
vous remarquez même pas oui mais alors
ici à lèvres est actuellement des mots
ce néo mais le tout sur le gaz et l'état
80 euros qui est passé à 1000 euros les
anglais qui s'est longtemps à une il est
mort à cause de la guerre qui n'est pas
je n'ai pas qu
il ya eu déjà le co vide il ya eu déjà
le coup alors il se servait au procès un
prétexte c'est un prétexte si sergei
dernière question ouais moi je vais te
libérer motion qu'est ce qui pourrait
faire reculer vladimir poutine
aujourd'hui où est-ce que ici c'est plus
possible de revenir en arrière et de à
lui faire comprendre qu'il est dans le
tort s'il ne s'y rend pas et faire
comprendre à son entourage et que la
seule façon pour moi la seule façon pour
moi actuellement de s'en sortir pour
tout le monde sait que cet homme
disparaît
c'est la seule façon dont qui est serré
seule issue pour nous parce que c'est
lui le symbole de cette guerre mais pour
la russie aussi parce que si lui il
disparaît les gens autour de lui peuvent
dire c'est lui le responsable et nous et
on revient à la situation dans ton est
donc lui c'est le principal frein
actuellement cette guerre est ce ce que
j'ai dit aujourd'hui
c'est lui actuellement l'homme le plus
dangereux sur terre le plus dangereux
sandra jamet